victor hugo avait 23 ans il n'avait pas
encore publié notre dame de paris et il
écrivait à propos de la cathédrale il y
a deux choses dans un édifice son usage
et sa beauté son usage appartient au
propriétaire
sa beauté à tout le monde à vous à moi à
nous et c'est pour lui rendre sa beauté
que les meilleurs artisans vont oeuvrer
dans les prochaines heures
cinq ans comme le réclame emmanuel
macron personnellement je tablerais
plutôt sur des décennies que sur
quelques années en termes de travaux
mais ce n'est pas qu'un avis personnel
cet expert est rejoint par d'autres qui
juge le calendrier ambitieux entre 10 et
15 ans nous paraît paraît raisonnable
première étape à sécher et assurer la
solidité de la structure qui va falloir
monter un échafaudage avec un parapluie
pour pouvoir couvrir la totalité de la
couverture qui a disparu pour assurer
une protection contre les intempéries
les deux chocs thermiques le show du feu
et le froid de l'eau ont fragilisé la
partie de la voûte qui ne s'est pas
effondré au sol les restes calcinés de
la forêt de notre dame
cet enchevêtrement unique de poutres de
chêne qui faisait la charpente de la
cathédrale un groupe d'assurance a déjà
proposé de donner mille 300 chaînes pour
rebâtir avec des arbres centenaires
mais difficile de reproduire à
l'identique
oui des relevés ont été faits sur les
plans de la charpente n'est pas dans
leur ensemble et en trois dimensions
il ya quelques trois dimensions partiel
ce que lannion ce qu'on essaie de
rassembler c'est la totalité de la
charpente en trois dimensions quant aux
oeuvres d'art les plus grands tableaux
n'ont pu être déplacé la fumée les
endommager la couronne d'épinés du
christ et d'autres artefacts ont pu être
mis à l'abri à temps et seront hébergés
au louvre tout en haut de la flèche le
point culminant de notre dame
c'était un coq l'emblème de la france il
s'est effondré
mais ce soir il renaît de ses cendres
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal